ces images ont fait le tour du monde sur
le tarmac un avion des gardes côtes
japonais est entré en collision avec un
appareil de la Japan Airlines au total C
personnes sont mortes dans l'accident
alors comment un tel drame a-t-il pu se
produire à l'aéroport de Tokyo aneda les
accidents sur les tarmacs sont-ils
vraiment rare et surtout cela
pourrait-il arriver en
France il est 17h43 lorsqu'un contrôleur
aérien autorise le vol JAL 516 à
atterrir mais sur la piste se trouve
déjà un avion des gardes co japonais le
choc est inévitable à 17h46 les deux
appareils entrent en collision la
première question qu'on se pose c'est
pourquoi est-ce que les pilotes ils
étaient trois à bord n'ont pas vu qu'il
avait un appareil aligné sur la même
piste lorsqu'on a posé ces questions au
pilotes ils ont répondu on l'a pas vu
pourquoi parce qu'ils étaient là en fait
et de nuit c'est pas impossible qu'il ne
le voit pas une équipe d'experts du BEA
était envoyé au Japon pour participer à
l'enquête sur cet accident enquête qui
devrait prendre un voire 2 ans la
vitesse le fait que l'impact se passe
sur une aile et dans les ailes dans les
avions ben il y a du pétrole et qui a
360 personnes à bord il a les
ingrédients on étaient faits pour que ce
soit un vrai drame bon le drame il
existe parce que comme vous le savez il
y a cinq morts parmi l'équipage du d'h
mais ça aurait pu vraiment être pire
d'autres accidents identiques sont
arrivés ces dernières années dans les
grands aéroports internationaux à Milan
en 2001 une collision entre un avion de
ligne et un petit appareil privé fait
118 morts plus récemment en 2022 un
Airbus percute un camion de pompier à l'
port de Lima sur les trois personnes
présentes à bord du camion deux sont
mortes et une a été grièvement blessée
mais le plus grand accident aérien reste
celui de tenerif en 1977 lancé à pleine
vitesse de Boeing 747 entre en collision
au sol le choc est inévitable l'accident
a coûté la vie à près de 600 personnes
alors si ces événements ont marqué
l'histoire de l'aviation les
catastrophes sont de plus en plus rares
on a déjà fait des progrès hein puisque
en 15 ans on a doublé la fréquentation à
aérienne le transport aérienne et en
même temps on a diminué par 5 les
collisions les risques de collision au
sol on dit qu'on aura 4,7 milliards de
passagers en 2024 et donc beaucoup
d'avions en l'air et beaucoup d'avions
au sol ou à proximité du sol on aura
probablement 45000 avions dans les en
2040 quoi au lieu de 30000 actuellement
alors comment faire pour éviter ces
accidents et bien certains parlent du
système antiollision mais en réalité ce
système est efficace qu'en vol ça
s'appelle unticass c'est un système
d'évitement euh et anti et anticollision
entre les avion qui vous donne des
alertes à bord qui s'allument quand vous
vous approchez il vous propose des
trajectoires des vitements en haut en
bas à gauche ou à droite le système à
bord d'Airbus qu'est-ce qu'il aurait vu
il aurait vu un avion devant lui que cet
avion soit aligné sur la piste que cet
avion soit 30 m à côté prêt à s'aligner
il aurait vu la même chose donc le titic
cas quand l'appareil arrive en très
courte finale ne sert à rien s'ajoute à
cela des rares confusions entre les
pilotes et la tour de contrôle pour
éviter ces confusions il y a ce qu'on
appelle du collationnement aéronautique
dire que le contrôle va appeler l'avion
par son édicatif il va lui dire Airbus
Fox papa par exemple alignez-vous sur la
piste 36 droite et le commandant de bord
répond Airbus Fox papa je m'aligne sur
la piste 36 droite donc ils sont deux
dans l'avion VO 3 a répéter ce qu'ils
ont entendu de la part du contrôle et il
y a le pilote qui a la radio dans la
dans l'Airbus qui répète qui collationne
l'formation que lui a reçu et donc ça
fait quatre personnes qui ont
normalement compris la même chose mais
aujourd'hui nombreuses sont les quasi
collisions des accidents au sol évités
de justesse en décembre 2022 un drame a
été évité à l'aéroport de Bordeaux un
avion de ligne avait reçu l'autorisation
d'atterrir alors qu'un avion de tourisme
se trouvait déjà sur la piste après
plusieurs mois d'enquête le BEA a publié
son rapport sur cet incident ce jour-là
seul trois contrôleurs aériens étaient
en service au lieu de 6 précise le
rapport c'est une profession qui est
extrêmement réglementée cette profession
là et où les syndicats sont très forts
j'imagine mal des aéroport où on demande
au contrôleurs Arrien d'effectuer des
prestations qui mettent en jeu la
sécurité des vols sans que eux ne
fassent remonter l'information ou
éventuellement se mettre en grève alors
un accident de plus grande ampleur peut
il avoir lieu en France la France a un
héritage extrêmement important dans le
aéronautique au niveau des entreprises
au niveau des aéroclubs au niveau de au
niveau du nombre de pilotes formés et
cetera et donc on a une on a un
écosystème aéronautique qui est très
attentif à la sécurité des vols est-ce
que les Japonais ont cette conscience là
j'allais dire que c'est difficile de
dire
non